because you beat in fantasy and
obviously or an apology but you've never
been in a kind of science fiction film
per say no not per se no not not
something with ray-guns er I mean when
my entire family went and worshiped at
the feet of Star Trek all I could see
that those guys are having so much fun
okay look at those phasers man get to go
on but oh he gets to sit in that chair
he gets to sit in the calm you got to
run the enterprise you know you know
well I'm gonna win the Romulans make
friends when they have the you know the
P let me play a peaceful Romulan I think
that'd be that'd be fun yeah cuz you are
a genuine big science-fiction fan on
assignment so when you got the call for
Star Trek you were genuinely excited
we've got a picture that you took of
yourself you can see that the phone
hands there
yeah do you you don't have to say that
dudes and stuff yeah
your ear dude suggests not a huge
[Applause]
I can stretch to spark
[Laughter]
but oh you are you love Star Trek I grew
up watching it every was on every night
at six o'clock and we'd have
competitions to see I'd be on the phone
with my buddy at his house and we'd be
on both have it on channel two and
zhanna six o'clock we'd have a
competition see who could scream out the
episode the soonest yeah well now listen
we alerted each of you to the fact that
you are both Star Trek fans and I
believe you've both prepared some
Trekkie trivia questions so the call if
you want to pop the kettle on I'll be
typing my desk I have I have Tom
I left I'm sorry I left them in my
dressing room
very good Oscar Oscar winning some way
to transport you there quickly wait a
minute the guy who plays Scotty might
know how to get my body broken down into
molecules transported to the dressing
room and back and I will I could get the
questions that way by hand I have some
experience of matter-transfer in fact I
have taken the liberty of bringing with
me my own personal transporter so let's
just energize
the cultures there should say
[Applause]
okay okay
gather yourself I'm prepared to be
amazed once more we bring Tom back
you're very good and lock onto that
coordinate up and energize
[Applause]
it's or diminishes the film doesn't
English talk show us your way Tom you
want to start you do will you do one
quest one to him Nicole if they don't
know the answer number one what did
Captain Kirk call mr. Spock in the
spores infection episode that forced him
to blow his top and put his fist through
the enterprise console as he was trying
to beat his captain to a pulp was it was
it something like you like it's
something half-breed right it's is it
was worthless half-breed that was the
first part then he called him Jojo the
dog-faced boy no you remember that I'll
be in the cage right next to Jojo the
dog-faced boy
his fists I know in JJ's film they do
that when they gets like yeah right
Nicole right
Spock was the ear guy here we go here we
go next okay
Harry Mudd returned in a sequel to his
first season episode Mudds women what
was that called I am Harry Mudd thinking
about it that was a season three mud
sisters so he probably came back again
would have been his second attempt
[Applause]
[Music]
you